OverWatch 2 is at a bit of a tough
release with thousands of players long
cues and bugs off the Wazoo it seems
like every single day there is a bug
discovered in this game so will
OverWatch 2 ever see the day with a
game-breaking bug being discovered
hey y'all before I get into the video I
have to remind you as always the like
button the Subscribe button and to ring
that notification Bell and as a reminder
to check out our merch with the link in
description below Tamsin loves it Ray
Thompson
right well my dearest viewers it is a
great time of year not only are we a
month away from my birthday OverWatch 2
has finally been released in top
finalized mint condition not really well
kind of let me explain very recently a
player named kapha uploaded a video onto
Twitter with the caption how to use
junkertown FPS bug to win ranked games
and this happened
if it isn't clear enough basically it
seems like kapha is shooting a spot in
spawn that causes both teams to have
incredibly slow FPS and allows his
Widowmaker to get the pick if dealing
with widows wasn't already annoying
enough anyways that's not great but you
might be wondering why would anyone
choose to trigger the bug if it affects
both teams well although it does affect
everyone on the map it's the attacking
side that has the ability to trigger
when they want triggering it at the
right moment could be way worse for
their opponents on the 19th blizzard
addressed the bug in a post and said
that they were actually disabling the
map because of a bug that could lead to
Performance issues but there have been
more bugs some of those bugs included
literally shutting off people's PCS in
case you didn't know you need the PC to
be on to play the game stay tuned for
more tips brought to you by tech support
Liz blizzard were made to disable two
heroes or send them to the workshop in
their words because of bugs that they
found those Heroes were torbjorn and
Bastion and their bugs well they were
already annoying enough to deal with but
just look at what their bugs did
[Music]
so torbjorn with the double overload and
Bastion with the unlimited bullets
during his ultimate Bastion and torbjorn
are both damage Heroes and those who
maintain will have to wait to see the
return at least in competitive play
luckily for them they didn't have to
wait long for they will be returning on
the 25th I could literally spend an
entire 20 minute video talking about the
bugs that have plagued this game since
its release I'm not kidding do a Twitter
key term search of OverWatch 2 bugs and
see all the things that I could not
include because I have a maximum word
count to keep under one of my favorites
was this person that said in their game
an on and mitigated over 5 million
points of damage which is insane another
one of my favorite Clips is this person
who literally gets stuck in spawn wait
wait the doors are shut all right guys I
can't get out the doctor doors are shut
on this one room stuff like that is what
I mean stuff that ruins the gameplay
of OverWatch too since it's released
I've seen tons of people in my timeline
talking about their play experiences as
well as making memes about heroes in the
game like this one about Moira that made
me laugh what I am trying to say is that
the game has pretty much solidified
itself into the cultural conscience of
us chronically online Gamers I've seen
tons of streamers picking up and playing
it quite a bit after its release like
this clip of shroud our social team
edited it was fun
oh my God
to be fair as I was writing this shroud
was being paid to play it so he might
just be getting the bag which
plenty people are still picking up the
game and playing there have been a fair
share of critiques with the game like
this one about its rank system but
OverWatch 2 saw 25 million players in 10
days but its bugs still overshadow all
of this I personally just started
playing OverWatch at the time of the
sequel's release and so when I'm not
getting Diva bombs
have fun guys
yay I'm still trying to actively learn
about this game I still don't know the
names of certain Heroes I mix Heroes up
I don't know what their abilities do I
fall off the map I am still learning
when stuff like this happens I literally
cannot experience a game at its fullest
potential I lose out on teaching moments
when stuff like this happens I literally
cannot experience the game at its
fullest potential I lose out unviable
teaching moments is it the end of the
world no it is a video game and I
understand that and plenty of games are
flawed upon their release remember
Assassin's Creed Unity but to the point
about OverWatch for such a hyped release
to then be played by so many bugs and
issues as a new player while I am having
fun I begin to lose confidence in your
game I have to ask when will this end
when can I experience your game in its
fullest and for the returning players I
actually would like to ask you will this
game ever reach the point of normalcy
that it did with its predecessor games
have bugs and glitches see any speed run
ever but to have such a rocky release is
where some of your most iconic Heroes
cannot be played
it's not a good look I hope for both the
new and the older players that OverWatch
2 sees a day with a normal amount of
bugs that doesn't see the removal of
characters and Maps constantly that is
with the 25 million plus players deserve
and we'll have the
featured in it
someone uh last video said that they
thought Tamsin was a dog
and while I know Tamsin is like larger
she's 15 pounds and like has like a bit
of a primordial pouch or belly
but she is not a dog I think she'd be
offended if you called her